your brother is joel edgerton and for
the last couple of years since he
started getting seen in a lot of movies
everybody has been telling me that I
look like your brother well actually
they said to me he looks like a
better-looking version of my brother
though you think I'm the better-looking
version of your brother that's what I
get told yeah yeah that's fantastic
I like your version I like your original
did I not tell you though they don't
tell me that I leave that was very nice
that you said that but here's a picture
of your of here we are let's put it up
there there's your brother yeah and and
then I think we have me he's trying to
look like you did yeah it looks like
he's trying to do me a little bit we're
talking
[Applause]
can I do yes why do I look more like
your brother than you do I don't know
but I think I feel I feel like I need to
talk to my mother about this let's drop
this now
you